hi
[Music]
my name is doba friedman
and i am a holocaust survivor i was a
child of six
when i was in australia
if you have any questions at all i would
love to answer them
and i'm very pleased to say that tober
friedman the author of the daughter of
auschwitz is here with us now toby
friedman it's wonderful to have you with
us thank you so much for your time so
much for having me here it's it's an
honor
honestly all ours um so you mentioned
there in your tick tock that you
want anyone to ask you any questions
what questions you get asked the most
about your time oh people are asking me
about
um
how did i recuperate how did i recover
how was i how was i able to have a
normal life
after such a terrible terrible childhood
and they asked me things like uh
what message do i have for the for for
the other those are young people who are
asking questions what messages do i have
wonderful questions very very sensitive
it warms my heart of the questions some
of them as as many as
200 a day or something like people
people want to find out your story yes
these are young people wow that's what's
wonderful young people my grandson's age
who's 17
aaron who did this tick tock for me
so tell us your story then um my story
is about how how you ended up in
auschwitz
well
many things happened before austria
i lost almost my entire family except my
mother and father and i had no siblings
and at the age of five and a half
my mother and father
went on a oh this is this is in poland
at light right after liberation
when we went back home
to fight family
okay and here is the picture of um
uh the russian army took it they were
shocked to see children being tattooed
so here we are and do you see those two
little children standing next to me i
just i just met them a few years ago wow
yeah and one of them was a a teacher of
one of my grandchildren
in new jersey it was like mind-boggling
her name is sarah and
how could you be covered teacher in
other words
there are a lot of miracles here that's
how i feel so take us back then so you
were you're five years old and you were
living in poland right right exactly me
in poland in a in a labor camp and they
put us on the train
and the cattle cars
and at five and a half
i end up in auschwitz my father goes to
dachau but he gets tattooed before
he is
sent to dachau
and uh when we arrive we get the first
thing they do they take our clothes away
and they shave our heads
so here i was and then they i and my
mother went straight into
into the barracks and we got a a middle
like i called it a shelf
like a bed but the miracle is that most
99.9 children of that age was taken were
taken straight to the crematorium
never even got into a barrack straight
from the train there was a miracle i
mean and this is why it's so important
to tell these stories because i mean
obviously you know the story i know the
story because i've read the books but
many people don't understand when in the
war this happened and how it happened i
mean this is so this is towards the end
of the war isn't it this is when you
were taken well
yes this is in 1944 right i would say
six months six seven months before the
end of the war because this was around
uh july i think and
uh
january
1945
the allies came and this happened to
your family at that point in the world
but of course the nazis had begun this
many years before way before that's
what's so scary right it started almost
um
within with the nuremberg laws the laws
about and you can't do this you can't do
that you can get married you can't walk
on the sidewalk you can't go to the
library on and on and on and on
but then once the war broke out and once
they decided how they wanted to try and
uh deal with people they began the mass
killings
sorry they began the mass killing of
people in mass killing uh when they
entered our town which is the top tomato
of mazavitsky just give you an idea the
beginning of the war there were 15 000
jews living in their town at the end of
the war 1945 300 were left
it's just incredible yeah the others
were were killed
it just just just murdered there were
thousands or hundreds of thousands and
hundreds of children jewish children
because the families were very large
at the end of the war five were left
five children
i was the youngest
so you can imagine the the the the the
enormity
of the murder so tell us once the war
broke out and you were living in that
town in poland did you understand what
was happening in other parts no no so
you had no idea that what no i was i was
a year old when the war broke out but i
did understand afterwards that we're
living in a ghetto in a very crowded
place and there was no room for me
so i sort of lived under the table a lot
most of the time i slept there i ate
there for space and for safety
because they were killing children
they were walking in to homes
finding elderly and children those were
the two populations that they were
murdering right away
in 1940 41 as soon as they came to a
town those were the targets and it was
industrialized they put people on trains
they they carted them away and it was it
was a process of the night exactly which
is
on the cattle cars to
to the uh to the extermination camps but
many of them were shot
right there
my grandmother was shocked right there
and i think my the parents of my father
were also killed right in town they had
met this mass graves
and
the people were standing naked and they
were shot in the back
and they fed the children also
and they fell into the the grave that
was in the very beginning later on the
trains came
because hitler had to hurry up
he was sort of seeing the beginning of
the end and he wanted to
speed up the process
so
tell us about the time when yeah they
came they came for you they came to take
you away and thank you
at that moment when they came to take
you and they put you on a train to
auschwitz tell us about that
we just went i thought that this is i
heard about auschwitz i heard about
treblinka i was five and a half i was
very well educated although i wasn't
sure exactly but i knew whoever when
they didn't come back so we walked to
the train as far as i know i was the
only child because the other children
were already taken away sorry to
interrupt do you remember what it was
like walking to that train were there
people screaming and crying where are
their people organized i mean like how
did it feel on that walk because we see
it in documentaries we see it depicted
in films
to be there i'll tell you my parents
were crying my father was crying my
father was crying and hugging me and
telling me to be good my mother was
holding me very tightly and it was a
type of a resignation
because everybody was going there and my
mother had lost her entire family she
didn't know what happened to them
inside the trade
when we was there for 36 hours
no food no drink
no place to go to the bathroom except
where you stood that's what the
screaming crying was
inside the train people were hysterical
the women were hysterical
uh
in fact it was so
terribl such a bedlam inside that i
tried to talk to my mother she couldn't
hear me
you know i kept saying i need to go to
the bathroom i wanted to tell her it
didn't occur to me that i should go
where i'm standing she didn't hear a
word why would it your child i mean you
know so inside and many people died
inside the cattle car in 36 hours
from
diseases from starvation from fear from
terror
because we knew or they all knew
i knew less as a child but they knew
that they're going
this is the last trip of their lives so
tell me about when you get to auschwitz
then well where i got the house you
actually arrived there
the door opened the first thing that i
got petrified were the dogs you know the
german shepherds they were my height i
was looking at them they were looking at
me i couldn't even see the saliva and
falling out of their mouth and i said to
my mother they're going to eat me
they're going to kill me and she said no
they only
trained to kill if you run so she told
me the truth then i said what is the
smell there was such a weird smell she
said dosa the burning bodies
she didn't like to me she told it to me
we were addressed every one of us
naked
standing there and i saw women standing
like like couples with two in two two
two two all the way out i said what are
they doing she says they're checking to
make sure
that we're healthy those that aren't
healthy go up there
she pointed to the criminal to the guest
chamber she pointed it to me and i kept
saying am i healthy i remember she said
yes you look okay and i said what about
you she said i am okay if she went like
this
to make this let's get some color in her
face the selections was there at the end
they selected you the moment you got off
the train and they made a decision
life or death right there and it was a
miracle that i wasn't killed because all
children
useless kids were useless all elderly or
till they were useless
but i just
i got into auschwitz instead into the
into the barracks
and this is around 44 so the war
obviously 40 40. war's coming to an end
so i mean i guess it's fortunate that
the war was at that end point yeah
because
there wasn't time for them to
to kill people no there was oh no no no
they speed it up just the opposite they
speeded up like crazy they killed they
all the hungarians were killed around
that air time all the gypsies
were gassed
at that time
all the people who came from other camps
at the last
few months i would say five or six
months they speeded up the machine
because they didn't want to leave any
witnesses and they didn't want to leave
any jews
both
and the gypsies and gay gave people any
anything that wasn't perfect that they
thought
would be so the machine speed it up
so what's what's your message then to
people who are asking you questions
my message is that
this is
auschwitz
is
the last solution that
or it's
it's what happens if we do not stop evil
before
i feel it's almost
it's like cancer if you have a cell
that's cancerous
and that's what i think of evil
as a cancerous cell unless you kill it
from the very beginning
if you let it go the whole body dies
if you let evil
continue on this earth evil prejudice
all the and and and the hatred of the
other
the one that you don't understand or
don't know because of color because of
religion because of
sexual or orientation because of
different from you
if you want to get rid of the other
the other
someday you also will be the victim and
that
the main thing is when you see the
beginning of evil it's your obligation
to help stop it what is that phrasing
the first day came
the first exactly exactly let's say yeah
so when you see what's happening in
europe right now with the invasion in
europe yeah i mean very scary
very very scary and and i would love to
see
people
marching for freedom
marching for tolerance i like to see
that i like to see people walk young
people walking out of classes of schools
out of colleges
and and marching
for stopping hatred
why don't you think we've seen more of
that do you think that people have
forgotten they're not listening to
stories like this enough they're not
reading enough books or watching enough
documentaries to educate themselves
why do you think that people haven't
mother people haven't
it's very
very hard to i'm the therapist it's very
hard to get it you know
whenever things aren't great people are
always looking for scapegoat is this
skateboard i think we have to some
educate people about scapegoats
scapegoating is not a solution
you will not feel better if the other
person is killed
you will not be richer if they lose all
their money maybe for a little bit but
your soul will die
with every person that you cause
his death humanity gets poorer as well
all of us lose um okay toby freeman i
mean just finally then just you know
you've got your your tick tock channel
that where you speak to people directly
um
tell us about that and yeah i'd like to
see more people like my grandson
you know he who who high school you know
he's high school kid and he reached as
many as 50
million
young people
and now he has educated them about
holocaust and about the evils and he
lets me talk and then they ask questions
and he answers them because he's also
very knowledgeable and i answer them i
would like to see
people doing that young people with a
conscience
but
because there's been a growth recently
of people who say that it didn't happen
exactly that's why i have my number
that's why you have the number yeah
that's why here this is what used to be
my name
27
63333
i was not a you know i was not a person
i was a number and do you know why
because it's easier to kill a number
than a person
just easier
if you are jack it's hard for me to call
to kill jack but if you are 25 it's
easier for me to kill 25.
that's what they did they took away our
hair
our clothing
our families and they branded us
it's
just been you know
amazing if there were more people like
aaron my grandson you set up your tick
tock all over you know
doing it on tick tock speaking in
colleges speaking
maybe
it's the young people we have to target
it's a young okay toby freeman i just
i'm humbled to hear your story and to
see you in in such great health and
vitality and i wish you a long life i
want to thank you it's people like you
by the way no
no no no that you have to take credit
it's people like you who will show it to
other people i don't know how many
people watch this program i mean i don't
know a lot right i hope so it's your
words people like you and what you say
and what you present right here can make
a difference
so
i want to give you a lot of credit for
doing it i want to thank you thank you
for telling your story again ms freeman
toby freeman whose book
thank you so much for being with us
thank you thank you